- As you can see,
Hampton DeVille blows
the competition away.
And star wipe...
The end.
- God damn it.
Now that...
is a PowerPoint.
- Thank you.
You know, I promised myself
I would crush this,
and I did.
- And the bullet bullet points,
brilliant.
Um...
I'm sorry, remind me.
What's your name again?
- Oh, shit.
Here comes Stockheed.
[upbeat rock music]
♪ ♪
- Christian, so nice to see you.
- Been a long time, Arthur.
Surprised you're still alive.
- Surprised you can afford
to eat here.
What do you have there?
- Oh, this is the sheep labia.
- It's nothing.
Just a little PowerPoint.
- Ah, top secret.
I wonder if it's for the CIA.
[tense music]
You know,
you're not the only company
to pitch the Bolivia contract.
- You may have won Iraq,
but your prices are as bloated
as your prostate.
You won't win Bolivia.
- The CIA will never deal
with Hampton DeVille.
Your products are not tested
on the battlefield.
Nice font, kid.
- Oh, thanks, I--
- Not.
[echoing] Not... Not... Not...
Think I'll leave you
to your sheep labia.
[ominous music]
- This font is all wrong.
This whole PowerPoint is a mess.
God damn it.
- ♪ Okay ♪
♪ You're a loser ♪
♪ Because you lost the fight ♪